when you're flying and and carl you
mentioned that
you can't even remember operations where
you didn't take fire
how often is your aircraft getting hit
you know that's you post flight really
heavily when you get back and you can
you know
when you're when you're a new guy you
can't hear
certain things but when you're got
experience
you can hear gunfire you can hear it
from a from 800 feet
you can hear it you can dang sure hear
it when you're breaking off target at
200 feet but
uh uh
back on but anyway the bottom line is is
that uh
uh we would get back on post flight and
uh more often than not
and we by the way we've we found uh we
would find uh
the seals would bring in intel stuff and
it would be
a drawing of a helicopter and in
vietnamese
telling the bad guys where to aim so
they could hit the aircraft
because most of the time they'd shoot at
us and hit the tail section
most all of my hits not all of them but
most of them were aft of the cabin
there were some in the cabin and they
were uncomfortable and sometimes
i know john got a purple heart and you
can tell that story
and i got one earl got one done i mean
it's no big deal i mean you get it
because you got shot and it's not
nothing necessarily heroic people think
a big a purple heart is a big deal it's
not a big deal
uh i'd give mine to anybody wants it if
i can have the hole back
period but so since you brought the
topic up uh this is something
yeah let's let's let's talk about it and
i talk about this all the time
and uh so we carl was on debt six
at that point and we were out and we
that one only had one of their birds
they had one in maintenance so
we went down to debt one and we formed a
three-plane formation
and so i was a pilot of one carl was a
pilot oneness earl shot
was a pilot of the third so we went out
took some fire found a target
and i'm not sure who was first one in i
think me
you he forgot to add it was a heavy fire
team and i was a fire team leader
so kyle those two guys are doing
everything i ask them to do
most of the time so carl's the first so
heavy fire team means you got three
birds three birds okay
so kyle's the first one in and you're
going in to do what what are you going
to do
putting a strike in so far when you say
putting a strike
in meaning you're going to lay fire down
onto
rockets is it close air support
necessarily or is it
taking some ground fire and we're going
to put it out basically
and so you're rolling in and then carl
was the first one in earl was the second
one and so
carl peels off and earl's putting down
fire so as he's peeling off
that's when the plane's supposed to be
put the second plane supposed to put
down on fire
so earl proton fire by that time carl's
supposed to come around
then when earl comes off the target i'm
putting fire down
i came off the target and that's when i
got hit
and so so we argued today i said carl
you didn't cover me coming off target
and he says well you were out of
position i said i wasn't out of position
you were out of position
so i got hit so where did you get hit i
got hit in the foot
so the round came up and knocked the
tips of my two
toes off tips of my toes off on my right
foot
and then you saw the scramble of sea
wolves my gunner that day
was he got hit at the same time kid he
was what
kid uh and the scramble of sea wolves at
the end
where the round came up cut his mic cord
came out
dotted his helmet and dotted the eye on
kid written on the back of his helmet it
was in the movie it was in the movie
yeah and it cut the back of his neck
like he cut it with a knife
yeah so he gets it i look back and i'm
trying to call him and he's not
responding i look back
and all i see is blood like oh geez he
gives me a thumbs up
a big smile and starts shooting again
and the round just
you cut the mic cord just graze the back
of his neck and of course when you cut
your
neck or head and it just bleeds like
crazy and then uh
so then we go back land carl comes over
picks me up and carries me into the
infirmary
the real story should we hear the real
story
well that's so and to this day we argue
who's out of position but we're the best
of friends
it's interesting that's like in a sealed
platoon
that's that's one of the basic maneuvers
we do it's like one person shooting is
that person rolls out there's someone
that's picking up fire right behind him
as that person rolls out there's someone
picking up the fire right here that's
the way it's supposed to be
carl that's the way it's supposed to be
in a race track thank you jacko
in a racetrack pattern this veteran at
that time i probably had
800 missions and fire it barely knows
how to pre-flight
yet he's in position and i'm not but
what's funny is we got back
and and i didn't know that purington was
wounded and we got
back and landed and uh john was
oh oh i thought my god he's
he probably has a body shot check his
body checked the blood and i couldn't
find any blood anywhere
i'm looking nothing nice dry i'm
thinking
and i picked him up and gently carried
him
600 yards down to infirmary the length
of the base he's moaning the whole way
meantime purington's bleeding and he's
walking chatting the whole time
but john's john's moaning not that he
must have
a brain wound i can't see or something
and
so let's just see what i put up and we
get down there he takes his boot off
and he shot in the big toe so earl comes
a little toes
earl calls you earl calls him nine toes
that's his name
so then i get medevaced up to ventui to
the third surge which is the army
hospital up there
and i obviously wasn't that badly
wounded and they put me in the back
room and that night
everybody came over to see me i had a
little nightstand table i must have had
30 uh scotching waters on that little
table
because everybody brought me a drink do
you save your boots the boots i do
i do and i was very lucky the doctor
said because it came it was
he had steel-toed boots but he came up
to the bottom and he said
just missed a steel toe he would hit the
sealed toe that would ricochet around
and
uh taking all your toes out john has the
boot on a nice little stand in his
living room
where there's a sprinkler around it and
music and so forth
he's got a plaque there but i do and i
have
actually i have the round that came up
okay
around from he's got what's around so
it came up with my foot and then hit me
on the side of the leg
and i didn't know you can only feel one
pain at a time and
it will hit me on the side like that
when i was getting out of the helo i saw
this round
down by the collective so i picked it up
and put in my pocket
was that two days later i was getting
out of bed and i bumped my knee
and i go geez that really hurts and i
had a big welt about this big around
on the inside of my thigh there and so
you can only feel one pain i just feel
my toes at the time a couple days later
i was feeling the other one
but that was around who was the ceo then
oh also the changed command that day i
got y'all was a change of command
and captain bergstrom was taking over
from captain twice
and the tradition was that the first guy
that got shot the co had to buy him a
bottle of scott
so he did it for a bottle of scotch so
there was a we had an officer's meeting
i don't know
a month later or something like that and
sure enough he gave me a bottle of
scotch
brought it back to debt and shared it
with the with the team
was it cheap i can't remember drew overs
or something like that